over the weekend donald trump held his
second
2022 rally these rallies now are very
clearly 2022 focused other than still
being focused on the 2020 election which
donald trump continues to claim falsely
that he won but the the rallies are
getting far more dangerous far more
insidious and corrosive they're
now actually starting to
uh sort of tease the idea
of more riots in the future if trump
doesn't get what he wants trump also
dangling pardons for the january 6 2021
rioters at this rally and the dangerous
part is
i don't want to say it's not the
dangerous part is partially that the
rally exists and the things that donald
trump says
but it's hugely
that there's a crowd of people who go
there thousands of people who want to
hear this stuff now we had two people on
the ground at the rally
they filmed some very disturbing
interviews including one individual who
admitted that he was in the capital
on january 6th and we of course will be
turning that over to law enforcement
we'll have those videos for you tomorrow
we had luke beasley and josh pitt on the
ground
for today we're gonna look at what the
rally actually consisted of now of
course the the framing of the rally is
always a lie in this case it was that
there were 85 000 people at the rally
there were not 85 000 people there there
were thousands though and that already
should concern all of us and in
particular
some of the claims donald trump made are
particularly authoritarian and fascistic
you know a principle of authoritarians
is they don't respect the law they use
the law as a tool when they can use it
for their personal gain but when the law
is an obstacle to their personal gain
they say they will go around the law and
that's exactly what donald trump did now
before we even get to that
um
trump
really struggling through this one the
teleprompter reading losing his place
getting confused just a couple examples
to set the stage for you know again in
this case trump's right eye swollen
almost completely shut and he looked
confused by what was on the prompter
here's just one example
dollars
they censor
cancel and
persecute ordinary citizens for speaking
the truth
while they drown your endless torment of
i mean what they do
they have an endless
list of propaganda and propaganda
methods so a lot of that during the
entire rally here's trump referring to
the country of
the mexico beneficiaries
it's such a good deal that mexico and
canada you saw that mexico and canada
want to get out of it and then lastly
donald trump
uh also looking extremely confused
talking about the sidister
faces of corruption lawless
this is incredible
but they're sinister faces of
corruption
lawless
yeah
just losing his place frequently but
let's get to the substance maybe the
craziest part of this
is that donald trump says if he is
re-elected he may um pardon people
and he is threatening unrest let's start
there trump actually threatening more
riots
if these radical vicious racist
prosecutors do anything wrong or illegal
i hope we are going to have in this
country the biggest protest we have ever
had in washington d.c
in new york in atlanta and elsewhere
because our country and our elections
are corrupt so he's saying there if the
prosecution
of the trump rioters continues in a way
i will say is unfair which he's already
doing
then we need to do more of these
so-called biggest protests and at this
point
everybody knows what that means
everybody understands that he's not
talking about peaceful protests he's
talking about more riots and maybe even
more per initially perniciously trump
says if he's reelected
he's going to look at pardons for the
people who did the rioting how many
people have been asking me about it
if i run and if i win
we will treat those people from january
6th fairly
we will treat them fairly
and if it requires pardons we will give
them pardons because they are being
treated so
unfairly
now that is not
due process and the rule of law
that is politically these people are on
my side so we're going to come in and
give them pardons even though i don't
really know anything about their
individual cases and the the the
important thing here is
consider how jarring this is in
comparison to the original story that it
wasn't even really trumpists that were
there it was antifa and black lives
matter the first story was it wasn't
trumpists it was antifa dressed as
trumpists it was black lives matter
dressed as trumpets there were some
peaceful trump supporters maybe but they
certainly didn't do anything wrong then
they shifted into it was a false flag
done by the fbi
uh ray epps and it was uh
tucker pushed this story
then for a little while it was i guess
the fbi and antifa
now it was trumpists all of a sudden i
guess but trump will pardon them because
they're not getting a fair shake they're
not being treated fairly so i guess it
wasn't antifa or more more realistically
it no longer matters to the story
because now the new one is elect me and
i will pardon these people now i many of
you probably would think if i told you
trump bragged about his dementia test
again you'd say yeah but david it's
almost february of 2022. didn't he take
that test like in the middle of 2020
he's not pro what you'd you would be
right
he's still bragging about the dementia
test take a look at this you know they
were getting a little nasty they didn't
like that we were doing so well
so they said maybe this guy's not with
it and i said ronnie can i take some
kind of a test is there something like
you can sir but it's very hard now the
number of times trump says sir during a
story
is directly proportional to
uh
it's inversely proportional to the truth
of the story so the more he says sir
the more untrue the story is we figure
that out and there's a lot of sirs here
i said what's hard well the first
questions are easy but then it gets
harder and harder when you get to
question number 30 it's pretty hard sir
i said well would anyone know if i did
badly right
he said well you know it is walter reed
a lot of people see what's happening i
better do well even that's interesting
because basically what trump's saying is
why don't i take it and if i don't do
well we just don't release it
he said what do you think i said i don't
know i did pretty well in my life let's
take it
and i took this cognitive test now it's
really again it's important trump says i
did well in my life so let's do a
cognitive test the test it's the
montreal cognitive assessment it's just
meant to screen for serious dementia
whether you did well in school or not
doesn't actually have a bearing on
whether you are now suffering from a
medical condition
he still doesn't get it
and as ronnie said i got every single
question right he said i aced him and
you know
from that point on they didn't talk they
found other things then they said he
wants to be a dictator he wants to be
they went on to other things but i think
biden should do the same thing ronnie
would you administer the test please it
would solve so many problems i have a
feeling he won't be doing it anytime
soon do you agree but seriously ronnie
jackson so there it's still a topic a
president a former president bragging
about how he passed the dementia test
then donald trump complained that
prosecutors are out there to get trump
unfairly
this causes the crowd to chant lock her
up about hillary but
how jarring is it that trump saying
there's prosecutorial misconduct against
me
and meanwhile the crowd is chanting to
lock up hillary who hasn't even been
charged with a crime i thought he was
about due process i guess not local
prosecutors in new york and other
locations who horribly campaigned for
office on we're going to get trump
this is how they campaign we're going to
get trump they know nothing about me
we're going to get them then got elected
and are working overtime to fulfill
their came campaign promises they've
subpoenaed more than
it's it's really something i mean he
says these prosecutors aren't behaving
correctly we have we everything needs to
be done the right way
yet lock up hillary who's not even been
been accused never mind charged
of any crime uh trump doing his supply
chain stuff of course can you believe
what's happened you can't get anything
the shelves are empty
i did a book they can't publish it
anymore they can't get the paper the
glue the ink
go out and buy it you'll like it
every opportunity to promote his book as
an opportunity trump takes and then
lastly maybe the one bit of truth from
the rally trump says when republicans
retake congress they will investigate
the biden family that he's probably
telling the truth about i do believe
they will do that and biden has the real
scandals and rest assured when
republicans retake congress the biden
corruption will be investigated and
exposed by congress
but we no longer have a free and fair
press if we did all of this would end it
yeah um i think he's that's the that's
the one piece i think he's telling the
truth about as i've said before i
believe if republicans win in november
they will investigate biden they will
investigate biden's family they may even
impeach joe biden won't convict in the
senate but they may even impeach joe
biden so an extraordinarily corrosive
rally and these are going to continue he
is going to play a role in 2022 later in
the show i'll tell you about
uh
or or tomorrow rather
new polling is not so good for trump
among the republican party but it's
certainly not stopping the rallies
as many of you know i don't play games
with my investments like timing markets
finding hot stocks meme plays
particularly in environments like the
one we're experiencing right now for me
it's asset allocation
and time in the market that's why our
sponsor masterworks io is so interesting
instead of limiting investment in fine
art to the richest one percent
masterworks allows everyone to invest in
world-renowned paintings like picasso
monet banksy and others art is an asset
class and it's outpaced the s p 500 from
1995 to 2021 and has almost no
correlation to the stock market and
masterworks is the first company to
offer paintings filed with the sec
as public offerings over three hundred
thousand investors have already signed
up in fact one of their latest offerings
by banksy sold out in under three hours
use my link under this video to skip
their wait list and start investing
today